well I think geneticists in general are
less and thought you know have an
underlying core belief that most of our
processes are biologically determined I
mean what is free will really is is a
major question I'm I mean at some level
it has to do with who decides is it this
basic biological drive that decides
whether you're whether or not you eat or
is it quote you who decide whether or
not to eat and then of course the
question is who are quote you I mean at
the end of the day unless you believe
we're metaphysical beings there are
neural circuits in our higher cognitive
centers and there are neural centers in
our more basil centers such as the
hypothalamus they're all they all obey
the physical laws of the universe and
talk to one another and so what we're
really talking about at least with
respect to feeding is who calls the
shots the basic drive or the conscious
part of yourself that might decide you'd
rather wait 10 fewer pounds I think
history is littered with examples of
battles between basic drives and higher
cognitive wishes and I'll leave it at
that and let you know let you conclude
for yourself which i think is the more
powerful
you